In most spicy foods, this is thanks to the
same chemicals that cause the burning sensation
on your tongue, namely capsaicin or allyl
isothiocyanate.
Capsaicin is chemical found in fruits of the
genus Capsicum, which includes peppers.
It is present, usually in relatively high
amounts, in the placental tissue that holds
the seeds of the peppers, as well as in lower
concentrations in other parts of the fruit.
The capsaicin works as a deterrent to stop
various animals, particularly mammals that
would crunch the seeds, from eating the fruits
or otherwise harming the plants or seeds.
It also functions as an anti-fungal agent,
which further protects the plants.
Allyl isothiocyanate, on the other hand, is
a colorless oil that can be found in things
like mustard, radishes, and wasabi.
Like capsaicin, it serves as a defense for
the plant against various animals, as well
as works as an anti-fungal agent.
These chemicals end up not only causing a
“hot” sensation on your tongue, but also
irritate the mucous membranes in your nose,
causing them to become inflamed.
This triggers those membranes to produce extra
amounts of mucous as a defense mechanism to
try to keep out whatever unwanted substance
or particles are causing the irritation.
This same type of irritation is why your eyes
may also become watery when you eat very spicy
foods.
The capsaicin or allyl isothiocyanate can
irritate the membranes in your eyes, causing
your tear ducts to kick into overdrive trying
to wash the irritant away.
This can make your nose even more runny as
some of the tears drain into your sinuses.
Capsaicin and allyl isothiocyanate also irritate
various tissues inside your body, such as
your intestines.
This causes your body to react by trying to
flush the irritant out.
This is why after eating spicy foods you sometimes
have the dreaded “liquid fire” poop.